so good good afternoon uh members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Mike whims I serve as director of the
waste management division for New
Hampshire Dees and I'm joined today by
uh Leah McKenna who's administrator of
our Solid Waste Management Bureau and we
do have uh a few things we'd like to
present to you that I think will be
responsive to the questions that you
asked represent of kraton and I want to
turn it over to Leah at this time to uh
talk about kind of where we're at in the
in the process and talk a little bit
about that rule making the formal
rulemaking process perfect thank you
good afternoon members of the committee
again leam McKenna and I am the chair
the administrator of a solid waste
management Bureau uh so when we last met
in October as you may remember we had
just uh sent out um the actual language
the pros language that we were looking
at relative to en vsw 800 which is the
landfill requirements and we were
opening a uh an informal public input
3-week uh input session and that closed
around November 8th and so when we last
spoke uh we kind of outlined about a
dozen of those changes and um right now
what we're doing is uh in we're in
receipt mode so that that period closed
we received received comments from 14
entities so you know uh general public
uh public interest groups industry and
Consultants um those
total page- wise about a 100 Pages some
of those pages are um we'll say we have
dozens of pages of actual comments that
we're that we're filtering through at
this time so what now what we're doing
right now is actively reviewing those
seeing what if you know what changes we
want to make based on all those comments
and um to answer your question
representative kraton on
timeline the formal rule making portion
starts when we present to the waste
management Council and I think as I I
think I mentioned in October but if I
didn't uh our goal is to present those
at their um the waste management
council's meeting on January 18th and so
that's what kind of starts the formal
rulemaking process in motion one of
those one of the portions of the formal
um rule making process is a formal
public hearing and direct whimet that we
we assume that's going to happen
sometime U March or April and with again
the goal to have these rules adopted in
effective uh on or before July 1 2024
expire so uh we wanted to address a
couple of the questions that uh that you
that you had both at the last meeting I
think you I think you kind of nailed the
two and so I'm going to turn it back
over to director whimet to address those
questions thank you thanks Leah and I
should also note that uh we're joined
here not at the table but here in the
gallery um Sarah uas Kern our
administrative or excuse me our
assistant director of the waste division
is is also here she and Leah presented
to the uh to the this committee last
time so we're all here and certainly
happy to answer your questions um the
one question that we were provided with
um relative to these rules was um we we
have in in the draft that was presented
to the public for comment um we had
established uh essentially amended the
rule regarding the the distance of a
landfill from a perennial surface water
from 200 feet to 500 ft and I believe
there was some I was not in attendance
but I believe there was some discussion
and and and and back and forth about
that last time and I've since received
some inquiries you know with some folks
being concerned that is that an
arbitrary number is it just pulled out
of the air is it uh you know why is it
just a number and why isn't it some kind
of performance-based standard and I want
to talk a little bit about that because
I think that there may be some confusion
about that um one of the things I think
that was said and we we had a little bit
of of bad information last time is that
um that that 500 foot setback somehow
represented an average of the
surrounding State specifications and
that's not actually true what what I
want to correct the record for that so
in fact um if we're looking at states
that establish a numerical setback
standard in feat um this would actually
be more conservative and more protect
than most other states it's or any of
the other neighboring New England states
in the sense that we think that as we
survey the rules of those States it
appears that they set they established
setbacks on the order of anywhere from
100 ranging up to 400 feet and of course
we're proposing 500 feet um so I think
it's it's that that I just want to make
sure we correct the record on that um
the second thing I want to say is that
it's not just a number and and um we
when we look at that number what we were
really trying to do do is we want to be
sure and there are already Provisions in
our rules and amendments to these rules
that make it very clear that when you
site your landfill it needs to be cited
in such a way relative to surface waters
nearby um that any release um can be
detected and investigated and remediated
prior to that surface water body being
adversely impacted by that release and
so we believe that extending from 200 to
500 ft just candidly gives you more
physical space in which in travel time
in which to evaluate a release and and
if needed um after investigation if
there is a need for remediation to
actually have a space to implement
remediation and and and address that
release so that it doesn't ad adversely
impact the surface water the the other
thing I want to mention is that um it
isn't just a number in the sense that um
if you look at other standards that we
have established already or will
establish in these rules basically a
rule that that states that the formation
the undisturbed soils beneath a landfill
can't can't have a a saturated hydraulic
conductivity of any more than 10us 3 cm/
second and that's a very commonly used
uh specification in
hydrogeology and um so if you were to
assume that you that any landfill that
would be cited would need to meet that
standard and if you assume that all the
soils from there to the surface water
body in question meet that same minimum
standard and then you also make
assumptions about average paracity and
the average gradient of the groundwater
table and you do a calculation on
groundwater velocity what you really
find is that represents about a
three-year travel time it roughly works
out to that and um you know there's been
I'm sorry slow down sure I'm sorry I'm
an artilleryman so just say that again
sure in other words okay I I'm happy to
do that now I did take hydrology in
college but that was before you were
born so you know some of those synapses
aren't firing real fast well I'm happy
to say there will be no quiz
but but um no I appreciate that and I in
in in more layman's terms if you if you
look at the equation that you used to
calculate groundwater velocity and you
make reasonable assumptions and you
assume that the formation the the soil
in the area beneath the landfill all the
way to the the surface water body meets
our minimum standards meaning that it's
no more it doesn't it doesn't transmit
water any faster than required than than
is the limit and you do the C that
calculation you learn that that 500 foot
setback equates to about a three-year
travel time
distance in what type of soil which so
that assumes a soil that is right at 10
Theus 3 cmers per second which for soil
type would be like a fine sand something
like that it's it's a so basically we're
establishing that as a minimum standard
for um you you can't what it's really
trying to say is you can't site a
landfill over soils that are you know
very porous highly conductive gravel
deposits or cobbles or anything like
that you're basically looking at finer
grain soils that impede the flow of
groundwater at you know more so than a
more conductive soil okay so I'm just if
you don't mind I'm just saying so what
you're saying is if the water in the
soil at the proposed site moves faster
than 10 to the minus three then that
site is disqualified that's right right
that's that's if it's slower than 10
Theus
3 then it's it can proceed through the
process potentially eligible that's
correct okay all right any okay go ahead
I'm sorry I could say a little more
about that so so there's been a fair
amount of discussion in the legislature
in the last couple of years about the
idea of a um of a of a standard that
sets a certain travel time and one of
the things that was in play in the last
couple of years was the idea of you know
Maine has a fiveyear travel time for
example
and then they allow you to reduce that
travel time distance um by up to two
years to make it three years if you have
a double LED um system or if you do
certain kinds of monitoring and the fact
is that New Hampshire's design standards
for L already meet those more stringent
standards so we already require if
you're going to site a a municipal Solid
Waste landfill in New Hampshire you have
to design it with a double liner you
don't have a choice of doing a single
liner so it's not like an a Beyond
compliance activity that's the minimum
that you need to meet so we actually
believe that what this proposed standard
would be with the 500 ft with our
current design standards and with our
other language that says youve got to be
able to to invest you know detect
investigate and remediate any release
before it impacts surface water we
believe that taken together those um
those standards will be among the most
protective in New England we think it's
an appropriate way having said that
we're still um uh evaluating comments
and take you know that that we've
received and we have not filed an
initial proposal yet um to put a finer
point on what Leah said the she's
absolutely right the first sort of
official rulemaking thing that we do is
to submit a draft initial proposal to
the waste management Council but what we
do following that and after we take any
input from the council is we then file
that initial proposal in the rulemaking
register and that launches the public
process essentially and then at that
point what we're directed to do we file
a fiscal impact statement with that and
some other documents with the office of
legislative services and then we um
excuse me with the legislative budget
assistant and then at that point we um
uh schedule a public hearing and and um
that that is actually an in-person
public hearing where the Public's
invited to come and give oral testimony
in a live setting and then we typically
would open a public comment period
following that hearing um during which
time the public is invited to submit
written comments um on on the rule and
then once that comment period is closed
we take all those comments and review
them determine whether we think any uh
adjustments or amendments to the
proposed rule are are are warranted and
then we would proceed to draft a final
proposal which we then file with uh the
the o with OS and then that goes to
eventually to a meeting at the Joint
legislative committee on administrative
review um yes
thank
you thank you all uh for joining us
today so I I just want to check in with
a couple of things that I heard and Then
followed that up with a question to make
sure that I I understand it correctly
sure so when when you were discussing
why the 500 foot setback is not simply a
number it's not an arbitrary distance
the first thing you explained was how
that distance was arrived at by looking
at some of the other states in the
region who use uh distance right for set
back and this gives us a more
conservative uh number within that range
uh and my initial reaction was that okay
well that's all in well and good but
that still doesn't tell me that there's
science behind that number it doesn't
make it a less arbitrary number without
knowing what the science is then you
explained given some of the average
travel time right uh that works out to
about three years uh travel time right
and so that to me is is compelling
because it that to me is a a an outcome
that is based on science right so my
question then is which is obviously
repeating a question I've asked before
why why don't we have the regulation in
travel time and not in distance because
distance is an arbitrary number unless
you then can explain it in terms of
travel time and that to me is the actual
determination for
distance that's terrific question thank
you repr of J and and actually the the
answer to it is that I think goes back
to some of our testimony from last year
in this past sou session and that is
that
um the ability to if you set if we set
for example say we said that you have to
be at least three years travel time
distance from any surface water body
that then it would be incumbent on the
applicant to gather enough hydrogeologic
data to demonstrate that which they
might be able to do in certain
circumstances in other circumstances
they might not they might not own all
the land or or you know that's between
them and the surface and every surface
water in all directions um they may not
be able to and once they do it what I've
said is that that that kind of
regulation in my view is a bit of a
regulator's nightmare and the reason I
say that is that as a regulator when you
have a standard you want to be clear
whether someone isn't complying with it
or not and you don't want it to be
subject to a lot of argument among
experts and I can tell you you that if
we set a standard that looked like that
I think we would end up in a place where
um we'd have the applicant articulating
that yes my my my my placement of my
landfill meets that setback and here's
the data to demonstrate why and we'd
have experts on the other side of the
issue submitting arguments why that's
not the right way to calculate it and
the reality is hydrog geology is is not
the same as um you know a lot of
mechanical engineering problems there's
a lot more uncertainty in terms of
formation things are very the systems
are very heterogeneous they don't they
don't always uh they aren't uniform
throughout the formation and so our
feeling is is that with a travel time
setback we would end up with um a lot of
times that issue being subject to appeal
which can sometimes take a couple years
to resolve um and then they become very
difficult for the courts to resolve them
because in the end they are technical
arguments not legal arguments and one
advantage of um a 500t setback
particularly when it's tied to the uh
the technical basis that I discussed is
that most people have a hard time
arguing about whether 500 feet is 500
feet it's pretty clear standard um and
so we believe that that setting a number
like that a distance like that uses the
technical protections that we want to
see but makes it much easier to
implement much more effective and and um
and easier to enforce and that's why we
believe that's a superior approach to
this than doing what you
suggested representative BBY yeah so um
you mentioned that that 500 foot setback
is also combined with a requirement for
uh a maximum U paracity of the soil uh
and conductivity of the soil so that the
uh so that anything that uh is more more
porous or more conductive would make the
site ineligible is that correct yeah and
understand that 10 the minus 3 standard
applies to the formation underlying the
footprint of the landfill okay and so
how far out from the
borders uh from the landfill border does
that
extend it's basically the footprint of
the landfill including really
essentially the liner system and the BM
that that that anchors the liner okay so
if the the area that is directly under
the landfill and the liner Etc meets
those standards but the area immediately
outside it is more porous uh would there
be a risk of uh of problems with lee8
spills when the lee8 was
transported certainly that if if the
area outside the landfill footprint is
more porous then then contaminants and
groundwater will travel faster than it
would if it were less porous
um we we again if you take these in
concert with all the requirements we do
have a requirement that says as I
mentioned earlier that you need to it
needs to be cited and the hydrogeology
in the study of hydrogeology of the site
needs to support that a release would be
able to be investigated detected
investigated and remediated prior to
adversely impacting a surface water and
that that provision is still in there
and effective and operative regardless
of what um you know other conditions
might be present or not present okay so
uh if the if the soil outside the
perimeter of the actual landfill
footprint which is but was what but is
still within the property limits of the
landfill owner if that
is uh how would
you uh judge whether the uh a landfill
met the requirement to to be able to uh
detect uh and remediate within the uh
within that time frame without having
some more data about what the uh the
soil is like between the landfill
perimeter and the surface water
body typically we're we're going to have
more information certainly than just the
the footprint of the landfill in terms
of soil type and and and aquifer
characteristics so our hydrogeologists
would look at that information and make
a judgment call as to whether it meets
that standard the standard being being
able to detect remed investigate and
you thank you Mr chair so another
question I had and I apologize I had the
U I printed out the the Draft rules and
I'd written all these great notes and of
course it must be in a different folder
binder uh so I can't reference the
specific um section that I have in mind
but but um in in one area of the Draft
rules which provides for extra
protections and I forget you know if
it's around schools hospitals I forget
right so uh my recollection is this is a
thousand foot buffer 500 feet of which
has to be vegetated right there has to
be vegetation and so what I'm wondering
is why that is not just a good rule for
going to go by feet I understand um some
of the the things you you you pointed
out before about the complexities of of
using a simple uh simple in quotes uh
travel time but so if we're going to use
distance why is a th000 foot with 500
feet being vegetated which occurs
elsewhere in rules why is that not a
good standard for uh any body of water
or surface water sure I I think because
it's apples and oranges what we're
trying to effectuate with um uh distance
from those sensitive receptors that you
describe schools and nursing homes and
that sort of thing is not about
contaminant transport in groundwater in
the subsurface it's about noise and odor
and um vectors and that sort of thing so
it's it's two different it's trying to
establish a distance of setback that are
protections yeah I'm I'm G to go back to
your 500 foot thing because you said
something then said something else you
had mentioned in your initial opening
remarks regarding
the 500 foot also adding to the
distance of visible area where you can
identify
leakage um
and and but that's not the primary
purpose of the 500 the primary Pur 500
is
still the setback right or is it for
identification it well the the the whole
purpose of having a setback from surface
water is recognizing that um releases
can occur you know you could have a in
the worst case scenario you could have a
liner failure and you could have
leachate getting out of the liner and
getting into the formation um or you
could have leech eight releases um
because lee8 is handled routinely at
landfills it's it's designed to collect
leachate put it into a tank and then
pump that off and what typically happens
at most landfills is that that that the
truck comes and the tank is pumped off
to a tanker truck and the tanker truck
leaves the site and goes to a wastewater
treatment plant to discharge that for
treatment um so releases can and do and
have happened in that scen in that
scenario so the idea of the setback from
surface waters is in the event that you
have a release particularly one that is
is not visible so it's a it's a liner
leak or it's some kind of a a a leate
collection Plumbing problem that isn't
obvious when it it doesn't it's not like
you had a spill and you observed it so
the idea is that you want to have enough
distance so that your regular monitoring
systems like we have ground monitoring
wells around landfills that are intended
to identify releases of contaminants to
the formation and to the groundwater so
that once you have that data you would
still have time to react to it
investigate it and identify the problem
to make sure it's not ongoing and fix it
if it is and then if there is a
sufficient release that you think that
it might threaten groundwater quality
down gradient or the surface water to
give you time to complete an
investigation of that and develop if
necessary Implement an actual active
remediation which might include pumping
and treating the groundwater or treating
the groundwater in situ in some way so
that you reduce the contaminants so that
they don't have an adverse impact on the
surface water and the idea being that we
felt you know on on inspection you know
we're looking at all of our rules now
after many years and saying we're not
sure 200 feet is enough to is is as much
as we'd like to have in order to
accomplish that now it needs to be said
we we don't actually have record other
than for our unline landfills which is
another matter
for the for the line systems that we
currently are are regulating that manage
our waste um the double line you know
system our landfills that have Lee
collection we don't have a history here
of surface waters being adversely
impacted by those landfills um but
having said that um we want to be as as
protective as we can be within reason
and uh we think that expanding that 200
to 500 feet gives us more travel time
and more frankly just physical distance
in which to make an evaluation and then
Implement a remedy if that's needed so
and I am on the there's a ongoing
discussion right now on the leakage into
the aminos right how does that relate to
the lining that you just sure no I'm
glad you asked the question because I
know it's on a lot of people's minds and
actually we will later this week be
releasing a letter that explains the
agency's position on that that's a
complex matter that's that the you're
making reference to the ncees landfill
in Bethlehem at the northeast corner of
the landfill where there's a lot of
history that that that the the S has
been expanded there but prior to um the
19 early 1990s there was an unline
landfill at that site that was operated
by others not the current owners and
that had some significant adverse
impacts on um the groundwater in that
area I'm not sure there are documented
impacts to the amusic river itself even
from that facility but there certainly
were adverse imp acts on groundwater
quality around that landfill and back in
the early 1990s when NC was looking to
expand that landfill and construct a
line system there they um agreed to
basically pick up that entire unlined
landfill all the waste in that online
landfill and place it into a line system
on the same site now when you do that
you you have a great impact it
absolutely improves things because now
you no longer have that waste that is
that where the release of contaminant
that waste are not impeded by anything
because there's no liner you now put it
in a line system where you can collect
the lee8 and properly manage it um but
you can't undo what's been done to the
soil and the formation and the and the
groundwater at the site so um we've been
monitoring uh we have a system whenever
we have a site whether it's a landfill
or some hazardous way site we have a a
mechanism called a groundwater
management permit which is issued for
the site which requires that a network
of groundwater monitoring Wells be
regularly monitored and um evaluated to
to sort of make sure that the remedy in
this case picking up the landfill and
putting it in a line system has has been
effective at reducing contamination and
restoring groundwater in the area and so
we've had a groundwater management
permit for that landfill um for many
years and uh we continue to monitor it
it it has had impacts there's no
question most of the impacts were
related to what we call Vol organic
compounds or voc's um which were in much
greater concentration many years ago
most of those have declined as we would
expect because we picked up the landfill
um over time and and either gone to very
low or non-detect concentrations there
are two contaminants however that we
tend to see persisting at those kinds of
sites one of them is 14 dioxine which is
something we've known about for a number
of years but we have more more recently
established a much lower standard
drinking water standard for it it is um
actually a compound that was used
commonly as a stabilizer for chlorine
ated solvents it was also used in
household products um or at least it was
there present as a contaminant in
household products and it's very
persistent it does not break down like
most other voc's so we do tend to see
one for oxine lingering in the
groundwater environment much longer than
the other voc's and that has been the
case here although even that has been
declining um and then the other one is a
much newer contaminant for us and that's
something everybody's heard of past and
so the the the the issue with past is
that they're also extremely persistent
they do not break down readily in the
groundwater environment but they also
are regulated at extremely low
concentrations where we regulate almost
all the voc's that we regulate in the
parts per billion range or micrograms
per liter we regulate pasas and you know
for pfoa for example at 12 parts per
trillion which is nanograms per liter
which is three orders of magnitude lower
so we tend to see pasas at virtually
every landfill in New Hampshire um all
the unline land almost all the unline
landfills have it as present as a
contaminant even those that long since
saw their vocc concentrations go away um
and we do see it at our line systems as
well and in many cases that is um uh
attributed to um not necessarily a leak
in the liner but um releases of leech
because it's in leech eight when you
have a release of leech eight at a site
you you will get some and just candidly
I mean trucks you know driving in and
tipping their waste um p is so prevalent
in our environment that there are a lot
of ways that P can get into the
groundwater at a waste facility now what
we're seeing in the amusic or excuse me
in in that part of the landfill is that
um we see not surprisingly
concentrations of pasas um in
groundwater that we believe are
associated with the former unline
landfill um there are other monitoring
Wells where we believe there may be past
as a result of former known and
responded to releases of leech eight
during leech eight handling and we've
asked actually for additional work at
those around those Wells to evaluate
that um one of the things that's been
alleged is that there there as I said
it's a complicated area of the site at
this northeast part of the landfill
there's also a series of groundwater
seeps and a groundwater seep as you know
most of us have seen this somewhere you
see groundwater just emanating from the
edge of a of a slope or something like
that it's just an expression of the
groundwater table in many cases coming
out at when you have a change of
topography it comes out on the landfill
or excuse me on the uh on the face of
the of the soil in this case we have a
what we call the main seed which is not
very subtle it's about I think it's been
estimated at more more than 60 gallons a
minute many times depending on the time
of the year so it's a significant
discharge of groundwater on the surface
of the ground it forms a channel and
then that channel conveys that water to
the AMC River and um the one of the
unfortunate situations is that probably
as a result of geochemical conditions
that were caused by the unline
landfill but also just the actual
geologic conditions there um this the
the water that comes out of that seep is
very iron rich and when it it's it's
full of dissolved iron and when it hits
the oxidizing conditions of the air air
in in the open air a lot of that um o
iron gets oxidized and becomes insoluble
in that water so it precipitates out and
any of us who have wandered about have
seen this um if you ever come across uh
groundw or water on the ground or in a
pond or or even just coming out of a
Culver you'll see where it discharges
just um this gross sort of looking Rusty
colored film and that's the result of
iron bacteria that that that process
that it's a proc precipitated iron and
then the iron bacteria will sometimes
have waste products that almost look
like a petroleum machine um but it's not
actually petroleum so it's got that
rainbow Sheen um and we we respond to
dozens of complaints about this every
year all across the state often from
just purely naturally occurring
conditions but anyways at the seep it's
happened in Spades it's really quite
disgusting looking and noticeable it
caused a lot of concern on the on the
part of the public and we actually um
entered into agreement with um NCS many
years ago to remediate the seep in which
they basically took all that whole area
where the channel where the seep
discharges and then it goes down to the
river and we had them pull it all up
because it looked terrible and then line
it with rocks and and basically try to
make it look better it didn't work very
well because the water coming out of
that seep was still loaded with iron and
So within a few weeks or months it
looked kind of the same as it did before
but
iron as opposed to P right natur I
apologize I'm getting there I'm just
trying to give you some context so this
is an area that's been of great interest
to a lot of people because it looks
pretty ugly there are other seeps that
aren't quite as substantial as the main
seep we have required and CES to monitor
the groundwater qu or the water quality
in those seeps um over time and we we
basically the most recent sampling um we
don't see voccs in them but they but we
did detect um in a couple of the seeps
not the main seat but in a couple of the
seeps um low concentrations in the parts
per trillion range of pasas and it's
been alleged that that somehow has
contaminated the amusic river during
that same monitoring period we also took
samples from the amusic channel in the
river channel in the river water um in
three locations near that those
discharges and we do not detect Pas in
any of those samples so what I want to
make clear is that we don't believe that
the amusic river is being adversely
impacted by the discharges that are
associated with those seeps and the
seeps um essentially you can't stop them
they're going to run the water's going
to go there um we continue to monitor
them and and we'll do that into the
future but we don't have reason to
believe so the the data that we obtained
from the seeps did not surprise us
because those seeps represent
groundwater quality and we already knew
we had past in groundwater there and so
it's not a surprise that some of those
seeps have detectable levels of of um
pasas in them but they're not at a
concentration that we believe is having
any adverse impact on the quality of the
river repr B yeah so does the uh I
assume that it's some sort of an aquafer
that leads to the seep from uh where
whatever the sour source of the
groundwater is does that aquifer run
under the landfill or is it adjacent to
the
landfill it it does run under it in the
sense that when the when the unlined
landfill was um removed and placed in a
line system a line system was
subsequently placed over the footprint
of that former unline landfill so
there's a line portion of the landfill
that overlies certainly at least some of
the groundw that contributes to probably
groundwater that contributes to the
discharges in the
seat
and so you're going to you're providing
a response paper there will be a letter
response coming later this week that's
correct okay and any other
questions thank you dig just is another
one of those um you know uh make sure
that I I heard you correctly and I
understand the explanation so the the
way I POS this question in my mind is
you know what would a leak look like
right as opposed to what you're seeing
right so what I'm hearing is that what
you're seeing is consistent with typical
groundwater quality levels of of of the
things you're testing for as opposed to
what what would a leak look like
qualitatively right that that makes you
feel confident that that is not what is
happening here sure thanks for the
question so first of all I would say you
know having past and one for oxine At
Any concentration of water I wouldn't I
hope we don't get to a place where we
say that's a normal level because we we
certainly have groundwater in the state
where we don't detect past and that's
the way we want it so but in terms of
the conditions in the history of the
site where it housed an online landfill
it doesn't surprise us that we're seeing
those concentrations so I want to be
clear about that but it's a great
question so what would you know if we if
we were concerned that there were a
liner leak what would the groundwater
data be that would lead us to that
conclusion and um the answer is that um
there are a number of geochemical
parameters and vult organic compounds um
that we would see significant changes in
so um there are voc's in lee8 and there
are um you know leate is is very
relatively strong um solution it's got a
lot of contaminants in it from the
landfill so when if we had a liner leak
there where the leachate was actually
leaking we would expect to see um you
know chlorides we'd accept to see
increases in certain geochemical
parameters oxidizing condition um pH but
also the presence of Al organic
compounds that shouldn't be in
groundwater anywhere that would be part
of lee8 and when we when we have seen
leachate releases before we don't have a
situation where we had a liner leak that
we're aware of but when we've seen
leachate releases as a result of a um
mistake in pumping off a tank or
something like that in a in an accident
um we tend to see the impacts from that
tend to include not just pasts or4
dioxane but um voc's those other
geochemical parameters and that's not
what we're seeing in the groundwater
data or the seep data that we've
collected most
recently so what you're seeing looks
like
residual
old um stuff that was left over from the
previous one not what you would normally
see in a active landfill right primarily
we believe we're looking at effects of
the old online landfill we do have some
concerns that um you know folks are
aware that there was a lee8 release um
that occurred not from a liner leak but
from a an accident with a with a with a
mechanical failure um we've been
investigating that we think that the
effects of that were largely mitigated
by what was done in the days immediately
following the release but um we do have
some concerns that we're following up on
and this is something that's always
ongoing in every landfill where we we
see some data we have some concerns
about it and we ask for further hydrog
ological work to assess it and in fact
we responded to um that most most recent
submittals from the company that I've
been talking about the data they
collected with a letter that was dated
November 7th which laid out some
additional work that we'd like the
company to do to evaluate um some of the
um data that we're seeing in a couple of
those Wells so there's still more work
going on but nothing we've seen suggests
that we have a failure of the liner
questions you got every word of
it
um okay so based on the 18
January
meeting uh when would you recommend that
we have our next discussion on rules
before or after that meeting well I I
mean I think probably after we and again
I want to say we're going to do our
level best to get those ready for a
review or for your presentation to the
waste management Council on the 18th of
January we've got legal review we got to
complete the rules draft we've got to
get legal review completed and you know
we got a lot we have a lot of moving
parts right now we have many chapters so
um we're going to do our very best to do
that if we stay on that schedule um then
you know at that point the the whole
process becomes it's been pretty public
already but it becomes very public at
that point the the the the draft is
published in the room making register it
goes out to a hearing and public comment
and then really um everything that
happens in there will be evident to
anybody who's looking on but we're
certainly happy to come and uh provide
an update to this subcommittee whenever
it uh whenever it pleases you um I mean
obviously we'll we'll be in the session
at that point so we'll be here pretty
frequently on other bills and uh if it
uh would be helpful and you want to SK
certainly it's your pleasure if you want
to schedule an update we'd be happy to
uh accommodate okay representative
victory yeah so I have a question that
um it it's uh doesn't have to do with
the spill it's uh just in terms of
whether something is dealt within the
rules at all or not um and whether it's
something that would could be dealt with
Justin rules or whether it would require
more legislation so uh I'm um I was uh
told that um TurnKey in Rochester does a
certain amount of pre-treatment of the
lee8 before they send it off to
municipal waste plants and that is a and
and that step reduces the amount of uh
pasas and other contaminants that end up
going into the municipal uh waste
processing which would then not
potentially end up in the bio sols uh
and I was wondering if there is any uh
any place in the rules that uh uh does
or could require that sort of
pre-treatment at all
landfills there's nothing in the rules
that requires the landfill to pre-treat
their leech a on site there are rules
that make it very clear that a landfill
has to have at least two um identified
facilities that can accept all of their
leech eight um the idea being that you
know leech eight keeps coming whether
you want it or not you got to be able to
collect it and get it shipped off site
for for proper treatment um every day
basically so it's an important you know
institutional thing for a landfill to
have established that they've got an
outlet for their um for their leech a
and if for some reason one of those
Outlets you know a wastewater treatment
L goes down for a week they need to have
another facility where they can bring
the Lee a to while they wait for that
one to come back online in the case of
TurnKey that the story behind that as I
understand it and certainly the company
officials could give you probably a more
accurate view but my understanding is
that they were um you know it's a big
landfill generates a lot of leech a and
they have a number of places where they
send their leech eight one of which is
just to the local Rochester wastewater
treatment plant and it turned out that
as I understand Rochester had a UV um uh
disinfection equipment for their final
treatment of their their treated
effluent before they discharged to the
river at the plant site um and there was
something in the lee8 from turny
landfill that was blinding that in a way
that it wasn't becoming effective for
disinfection so the city of Rochester
asked them to pre-treat their leachate
to remove that compound to make sure
that it wouldn't frustrate their
treatment and disinfection processes so
they did that many years ago so that the
leachate that they sent to Rochester
wastewater treatment plant would be
acceptable and it wouldn't cause the
Rochester plant to violate any of its uh
permits um in the meantime um so they
have a pretty sophisticated Wastewater
sophisticated wastewater treatment plant
at TurnKey um and if you're Ted it's
it's pretty impressive there's quite a
lot of infrastructure there to
accomplish that um as it turns out um
they do a step called reverse osmosis on
the tail end of that there's a variety
of treatment processes that they subject
the leech a to but on the final
polishing they actually um submit it to
reverse osmosis turns out reverse
osmosis is a really good method for
treating pasas and so when they were
implementing that regular treatment it
was really pulling out a lot of the pas
now it's not perfect because it means
that it doesn't destroy it it just it it
it concentrates it if you will into
What's called the reject a reverse
osmosis water treatment terms and then
they have to find a place to take that
right so there's um a lot of stories
about how that unfolded and so long
story short TurnKey is doing that there
are other landfills around the country
that are looking at this um I think that
um what's happening so far is that to
the extent that landfills are choosing
to pre treat on site in some cases
around the country it's because the
wastewater treatment plants where they
bring their leech heate have asked them
to do so it's not something that's
required in Most states rules and it's
not required in our rules it's something
I think we can we will we are looking at
and we probably should look at in the
future I do want to point out that it's
a double-edged sword because one
advantage of collecting Lee at a
Landfield site putting it in a truck and
getting it off the site is that you you
minimize the handling of it basically
goes it gets collected it goes to a tank
you off offload that to a tank truck and
off it goes if you build infrastructure
on the site you have the added concern
well what if you have a release from
your treatment infrastructure so I I
haven't really kind of figured out where
we ought to be on it to be honest with
you it's something that I think is you
know different people could could
reasonable people could take opposing
views on something like that about
whether that's the right thing to do or
not and I think that you know as time
goes on we'll learn more about it and I
think that you know it may the market
may drive it even if we didn't drive it
through a regulatory Direction because
wastewater treatment plants may find
themselves in a place where they don't
want leachate that has pasas in it and
they may ask for pre-treatment there's
also been discussion about the idea of a
a regional pre-treatment facility that
would be separate from a landfill site
but would be constructed um primarily to
take lee8 from landfills and and
pre-treat it and either do a full
treatment there and discharge it or
pre-treat it in some fashion and then
ship it to um other wastewater treatment
plants for further treatment and
discharge so it's it's a complex
question but it's definitely something
we're thinking about right I guess one
of my concerns is uh since one one of
one of the concerns of this committee is
the presence of pasas in soils and uh
one of the Avenues for that is the is
spreading of biosolids and one of the um
avenues for contamination of biosolids
is uh the that leachate being processed
in uh water treatment plants and uh that
so we don't want to have a vicious cycle
of um of the past you know being brought
from the landfill to the water treatment
plant and then having that contaminate
the the biosolid which then is spread on
land right now it's definitely a concern
and one of the things we're looking at
right now is what standards we should
set we did a lot of work on this over
the last couple years to determine what
standards we should establish for you
know maximum concentrations of pasas in
biosolids if you're going to if they're
destined for land application so that's
something that's still in process right
now um if we talk to the landfill
operators they believe that the that the
Lion Share of Pas that they get in their
leachate comes from the from the
disposal of Believe It or Not textiles
carpets and things like that that have
been treated with um with past
containing cleaners and and treatments
um and that they because they're they're
they represent you you have to look at
the mass balance too right you know when
it comes to um what goes into an mssw
landfill there's a lot of textiles that
go into one and so I'm not sure anybody
knows for sure but I think that they
that the
the landfill operators suspect that
that's a major source of the p in their
leech
eight there's definitely a movement of
foot to get P out of a lot of consumer
and Industrial and Commercial products
and as we make progress in that regard
the concentration of pasas in lee8
should go down but it's important to
keep in mind you know it's it's not
going to happen faster overnight
because the mssw in our landfills is old
and and it's you know and it's it's what
it is it's going to continue to generate
sure yep thank you out of curiosity what
where does the kind of concentrated
pasas when they remove it uh and then
you said that obviously still needs to
be disposed of it can't be destroyed but
I'm just curious where does that go it's
a great question I think right now and I
I don't like to ever speak for the
company particularly when I don't know
the answer for sure but the last I heard
from company officials that was going to
another one of their their facilities in
New York state for further treatment and
Disposal um
uh at one point the reject date was
actually going down to a wastewater
treatment plant in Massachusetts for for
treatment and discharge which for
reasons you can imagine didn't didn't
sit very well once people understood
that and then they they started sending
it out to a out of state to a facility
state we good good
all right well anything from the uh
folks out in the hinderland
chair sorry when you were talking
about the Le being sent out to another
facility and they process it or whatever
is that what other states do as well how
do other states handle these um the Le
shapes and and leape from landfills yeah
my understanding is that in virtually
every case leape from landfills is
offloaded oh I'm sorry my understanding
is that in all case virtually every case
um unless it's treated on site lee8 from
landfills is collected in tank trucks
and truck to um nearby or sometimes
distant um Municipal Wastewater plants
where it's treated and discharged and
and other states do those the same thing
that that's correct that's my
understanding
okay so uh I I I do have one last
question from the work that you guys are
doing a lot of detail a lot of um
attention to detail uh what what do you
need from us at the legislature at this
point
um I don't think there's anything in
particular I mean we we know we have a
job to do we've got our rules are are
due to be um updated by July 1 of 2024
and we're going to do our best to meet
those deadlines and uh really we just
need to keep our heads down and keep
working at it right now okay actually
yeah so along the same lines uh I had a
call from Senator Waters um and he was
going to talk with um commissioner Scott
and I don't know what the result of his
conversation was but the question was
whether there was going to whether more
funding was needed in order to make uh
in in order to enable to finish this
rules
process well I I I think certainly this
it has to be said this is a Monumental
effort we we you know having um
virtually all of our rules expire at the
same time is is not a great plan right
and what we want to do rules are in
effect for 10 years and so once you do
them you sort of get into that um
routine but what we'd like to do very
likely over time with the ability of
time to think about it and plan for it
is to start amending certain chapters on
the staggered schedule so we don't have
all of a sudden 20 chapters of the same
set of rules all come to at the same
time it's been a tremendous burden I
will tell you that um we have staff who
are working really hard on it and I
can't be I can't tell you how thankful I
am that they're so dedicated and capable
um having said that you know now to to
to we're we're we're in the we're in the
home stretch here um we got a lot of
work to do an appropriation of money we
probably wouldn't be able to get someone
hired and trained to to help us in time
if we' had that five years ago we'd
certainly make use of it right now I
think it's no secret that our Solid
Waste program has been kind of uh sort
of chronically underfunded for many many
years and resulted in a lot of lot of
struggles um in terms of keeping up with
our workload and getting things done I'm
happy to say we we did we have seen an
influx of funding that has helped us um
you know higher St staff you know
recruiting staff and keeping staff is
difficult for everybody right now so
that is what it is but to the extent we
can maintain the staff that we have and
and get it you know get our work done I
think we're going to be okay there's a
lot of Demands being placed on us as an
agency with regard to solid waste that
maybe weren't a few years ago um so we
may need to look at that and having you
know more more Staffing um but for the
time being in terms of dealing with this
immediate problem the rulemaking I don't
think add dist funding would be that
helpful to us okay so so the I think he
was looking at uh using one of the bills
that had been retained by the Senate and
uh I think that um it sounds like the
really the appropriate place for this
would be the next bional budget I think
that's right and I and I will say you
know I certainly we could I'm not going
to tell you we got everything we need we
if we had you know another landfill uh
permit engineer and another compliance
inspector ctor um that would be really
helpful we did lose our our rulemaking
person um to illness uh for many many
months and that really hurt us that's
not something that you know an
appropriation or anything else can help
that's just bad luck and that's when you
manage people that's what happens yeah
um but um you know certainly we'd be
happy to engage in that discussion in
the next bium for sure I appreciate the
question well thank you all for your
hard work and uh we will not bother you
until after the 18th
uh recognizing you you're crunching on
all that um but probably before the end
of January we'll have our next
subcommittee just to check in with you
see how that goes and see how your
public uh hearings are going we look
forward to it all right thank you so
much appreciate it have a great day
Merry
m